here now with reaction author of
probably the most timely book heading
into the midterms defeating big
government socialism and saving
america's future fox news contributor
former speaker of the house newt
gingrich
so nancy pelosi now you went to china
what year did you go to china are you a
speaker at the time correct 1999 you
went to taiwan rather than 97. yeah well
both i went to china and taiwan
right so you went to you made your trip
to asia
and
if i remember correctly i think you had
some of the same threats pushed back
about taiwan no
oh sure
yeah we had a big crisis in 96
president clinton sent two u.s aircraft
carriers to the straits of taiwan i went
on tv and strongly supported him the
chinese dictatorship
invited me to come to china to give
speeches in shanghai and beijing we told
him we were going to go to taiwan and
they went crazy
and said oh you can't do it you can't do
it. and finally we said to them look
if you feel that strongly we're going to
skip china and go just to taiwan and say
uh why don't you come to china but and
then the compromise was i flew from
china to japan and then from japan to
taiwan so i didn't sort of rub their
face in it but i think
speaker pelosi now
has no choice
uh now that it's out in the open now
that the chinese communists are dancing
around and making threats and all that
she has to go to taiwan
because to back down now
would encourage every aggressive
bullying attitude of the dictatorship
and i think would be a disaster and i'm
hoping in the next day or so we're going
to see her in taiwan i frankly think the
chinese communists will then calm down
you know they're running a bluff
the fact is they're not going to take on
the united states they're not going to
take on the speaker of the house
and
all these various threats are nonsense
they're not going to happen
if they did they're basically starting
world war iii are they not i mean
they're threatening to shoot down her
airplane i mean the worst case
look the worst case if they shot down
her airplane that would be literally an
act of war and we would have no choice
except to retaliate massively and that
people tend to forget you know the us
despite the weakness of the pentagon
despite all the truly woke stupid
behaviors we still have a powerful
enough military you can
with our allies in australia and in in
japan and elsewhere we could isolate
china very fast if they can't export
they start to go broke their cities
start to have unemployment if they can't
import they begin to starve
so the chinese are not necessarily in a
strong position to try to bully us and i
think that we need to recognize that and
it's really important when you're
dealing with a dictatorship to stand up
to them and make them realize that
reality is that there are real limits to
what they can accomplish if we were to
cave right now
who knows psychologically what they
would conclude from that and about
whether or not they would then decide to
push us even further by trying to occupy
taiwan
they're calling it the inflation
reduction act meanwhile the middle class
are going to get hammered at a time when
they can at least afford it with higher
taxes
only washington d.c can call something
just the opposite of what it is but
that's what they're trying to do here
why manchin gave into this i don't know
it'll hurt the people of west virginia
but it it now is what it is the
inflation reduction act that the wharton
school of business and congressional
budget committees are saying no we'll do
no such thing it won't reduce inflation
it'll increase inflation
look i mean i can't figure out why
mansion would have approved
a bill
which raises taxes on coal directly
hitting west virginia well let me go a
step further this this act is an entire
lie i was very proud over the weekend
that herschel walker running for the
senate in georgia
challenged senator warnock who's a very
articulate preacher and all that stuff
he said to him why don't we in august
have a debate
on this bill warnock promptly said no
chance he's not he's not going to do it
i thought it was fascinating i think
every republican candidate in the
country
should challenge their opponent to
defend what i think is the tax increase
87 000 more internal revenue agents
higher spending
greater inflation bill which is what
this really is i also have a challenge i
want to take this chance to put out i
think the senate republicans have an
absolute obligation to use every
procedural process to stop this bill
from getting voted on before the recess
if this country gets to look at this
bill throughout august it will die
there's no possibility that a senator
running for reelection in the democratic
party wants people back home
just just a single question you really
think we need 87 000
more irs agents that's they're only 77
000 right now that's more than doubling
the number of irs agents i don't think
mark kelly can go home and survive
saying voting for that
by the way that that means everyone will
get the hannity treatment which is
puller's file even though it's gone
through two accounting firms in a law
firm mr speaker your book is timely i
hope these uh candidates take your
advice thanks for being with us hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else